le gouvernement cherche à réduire ses
dépenses mais au fond il n'a pas le
choix c'est que les revenus ne sont pas
au rendez vous et donc ils travaillent
sur la colonne des dépenses ne travaille
pas beaucoup sur la colonne les revenus
il est dans la continuité de son action
depuis qu'il est au pouvoir donc ce
n'est pas surprenant ce qui a été
annoncé aujourd'hui cela dit en même
temps faut travailler sur les revenus
faut trouver des solutions pour générer
de la croissance économique au québec
monsieur l'état au parlait durant la
campagne électorale d'une croissance du
pib cette année de 2,1 pour cent dans
son budget du mois de juin il a ramené
sa 1,8 pour cent aujourd'hui nous ramène
sa 1,6 pour cent et ils révisent à la
baisse la projection de croissance du
pib pour 2015 également mais qu'est ce
qui se passe comment se fait-il qu'à pas
davantage de croissance économique les
exportations augmentent rapidement parce
que le dollar canadien est en baisse et
parce que il y à un rebond américain
mais les entreprises au québec et êtes à
investir le taux d'épargné rendu très
bas les québécois s'endette ya de plus
en plus de contribuables qui déclarent
faillite il y a un enjeu réel en termes
de croissance économique présentement il
n'ya aucune mesure dans cette mise à
jour économique pour la création
d'emplois or la situation de l'emploi va
mal il s'est perdu depuis le début de
l'année 29 mai l'emploi perte nette de
29 mille emplois au québec en 2014 et
quand on regarde depuis un an depuis
l'automne dernier donc on fait pas de
politique on n'est pas en train de
regarder qui est au pouvoir depuis un an
et s'est perdue cent mille emplois à
temps plein au québec est ce que le
laisse que le temps n'est pas venu de
stimuler l'économie de stimuler l'emploi
et des petites mesures sur la relève
agricole pour les pme notamment qui ont
été annoncés aujourd'hui mais c'est
quand même minime par rapport au fardeau
fiscal plus lourd qui est annoncé pour
les particuliers pour les entreprises
sur 394 pages de mise à jour économique
aujourd'hui la peau grand chose qui va
stimuler l'emploi à partir de maintenant
malheureusement les contribuables à ça
commence dès janvier exact ouais merci
beaucoup gérald merci ces lignes